[संगीत]
ब
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग टू ल वेलकम टू डे
ऑफ दिस कोर्स बेस्ट मास्टरी कोर्स एंड एक
बार सब लोग मेरी य बता द आवाज आ रही है
नहीं आ रही आवाज को कन्फर्म कर दीजिए आई
एम ऑडिबल टू क्लियर यस यार नो करके बता
दिया और हम एक मिनट का वेट करते हैं बाकी
लोग जवाइन होने का उसके बाद हम अपना सेशन
कंटिन्यू करते
हैं
तब तक यह बता द सबको मेरी आवाज आ रही है
नहीं आ
रही ओके थैंक यू अली आप फर्स्ट क्लास है
क्या आपका
अली डे
वन
तो एक एक काम कीजिए अली अगर आपका फर्स्ट
डे है तो आप एक काम कीजिए हां के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको चैनल के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में क्या ना य टेलीग्राम का
लिंक मिलेगा वहां जाइए और वहां जाके आपको
क्या करना है कि चैनल उसको जो हमारा
अकेडमी का जो टे ग्रा चैनल उसको जवाइन कर
लीजिए ग्रुप है उसमें आपको क्या है कि
न्यूज प्लस में क्या है कि आपके डाउट्स
वहां पर लिए जाएंगे और मैंने रिसेंटली अभी
आज ही अगर आप लोग ग्रुप में एक्टिव रहते
हो तो आपको मिल गया होगा कि आज मैंने क्या
है मीडियम का एक आर्टिकल मैंने खुद ही
लिखा है मेरे लिखा हुआ आर्टिकल जो मैंने
आप लोगों को अभी तक पढ़ाया जैसे
स्टार्टिंग में हाउ बेस्ट प्रोसेस कमांड
लाइन उसी के ऊपर एक आर्टिकल लिखा और वही
मैंने आपके सामने शेयर कर दिया है
तो आप एक काम कीजिए उस आर्टिकल को पढ़िए
और आपके एज ए नोट्स बहुत काम आए उसको बुक
मार्क कर लीजिए सेम आर्टिकल है कुछ भी
चेंज नहीं है जो वीडियो में सिखाया है वही
आर्टिकल्स में लिखा है और आपको अगर समझ
में नहीं आता तो क्या है वीडियो प्लस में
आर्टिकल दोनों रेफर कर सकते हो उसमें
वीडियो का लिंक भी दिया हुआ है तो वहां पर
अगर आपको कोई डाउट है तो वहीं पर आप
वीडियो चला के देख सकते हो और आर्टिकल पर
जो लिखा है वो मैच कर सकते हो इससे क्या
है कि आपके डाउट्स भी क्लियर हो आपको
नोट्स भी मिल रहे हैं तो जिसको अगर आपको
नोट्स बनाने हैं कि आपको लगता नहीं मुझे
आर्टिकल से नहीं पढ़ना तो एक काम कीजिए
आपको वहां से कट कॉपी पेस्ट कर सकते हो
अपने शॉट नोट्स के अंदर कोई इशू नहीं है
आपको पीपीटी देने की बजाय ये सबसे बेस्ट
वे है कि आपको मैं क्या करता हूं ऐसे ही
मीडियम से आर्टिकल लिख दूंगा कोई इ नहीं
मीडियम की मुझे कोई पब्लिसिटी की जरूरत
नहीं है लेकिन अगर आपको अच्छा लगता तो आप
मे को फॉलो कर लीजिए आपको व पर मिल जाएंगे
अदर वाइज और जस्ट
फॉर पब्लिकली सबके लिए अवेलेबल करवाया कि
इन फ्यूचर कभी भी किसी को जरूरत पड़े तो
आपको आसानी से पड़ सकता है उसका कोई भी
चार्ज चार्ज नहीं है तो हम चलो सेशन
स्टार्ट करते हैं तो आज का सेशन स्टार्ट
करने के लिए हम जो टॉपिक्स है यह हमारा
टॉपिक है आज हम पढ़ने वाले हैं ग्लोबिंग
जो स्टेप थ्री का जो पार्ट फोर है स्टेप
फोर है लास्ट जो फोर्थ एंड फाइनल स्टेज है
जो एक्सपेंशन प्रोसेस की इसलिए पहले इससे
पहले पढ़ चुके ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन ट
एक्सपेंशन और कमा सब उसके बाद मैंने आपको
बताया है कि वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग स्टेप थ्री
ऑफ पार्ट थ्री थ्री अब इसका जो पार्ट फोर
है जो आपका क्या है ग्लोबिंग है सेल
एक्सपेंशन का स्टेप थ्री का तो आज वो हम
डिस्कस करने वाले हैं स्टेप फोर कोट रिमोल
के बारे में डिस्कस करने वाले स्टेप फाइव
रीडायरेक्शन के बारे में डिस्कस करने वाले
हैं और आज हम क्या करने वाले जो जो आपके
कमांड लाइन कैसे प्रोसेस करती है उसको हम
एंड कर देंगे और कल जो नेक्स्ट क्लास
रहेगी नेक्स्ट क्लास में हम क्या करने
वाले हैं कल नहीं तो डे आफ्टर टुमारो जो
आपकी क्लास रहेगी उसमें हम क्या करेंगे
इसका एक पूरे एक दो एग्जांपल लेंगे
अच्छे-अच्छे जिसमें मैं पूरा बताऊंगा आपको
आपका रिवीजन भी हो जाएगा कि जो अभी तक
मैंने पढ़ाया है कमांड लाइन प्रोसेस कैसे
करेगी स्टेप वन से लेकर स्टेप फाइव तक वो
सब आपको क्या है कि क्लियर हो जाए कि ओके
हां कोड में कैसे चीजें काम कर रही है
आपके फिर डाउट्स बचेंगे नहीं आपका रिवीजन
भी हो जाएगा प्लस में आपका कांसेप्ट भी
क्लियर हो जाएगा तो आज हम कंप्लीट कर रहे
हैं उसके बाद कल के बाद क्या नेक्स्ट सेशन
हमारा स्टार्ट हो जाए उसके बाद हमारा पूरा
स्क्रिप्ट चलेगा स्क्रिप्ट कैसे बनाना है
कैसे उसमें कोड लिखना है कैसे लूप हमने
यूज करने हैं कैसे स्टेटमेंट हम यूज
करेंगे और साथ के साथ क्या छोटे-छोटे
प्रोजेक्ट्स हैं जो मैं आपको दूंगा एट द
एंड ऑफ द क्लास और वो आपको क्या करने
पड़ेंगे करके लाने होंगे अगर आप नहीं कर
पाओ तो मैं आई विल ट्राई कि नेक्स्ट क्लास
में हम या एंड ऑफ द सेशन हम उसको क्या
करें उसको आपके साथ डिस्कस करूं एक साथ
किसी सेशन में डिस्कस कर लूंगा तो हम एक
काम करते हैं अभी स्टार्ट करते हैं
ग्लोबिंग के बारे में दिस इज द फोर्थ एंड
फाइनल स्टेज ऑफ एक्सपेंशन प्रोसेसिंग य आप
आपको पता चल जिसे हम ग्लोबिंग बोलते हैं
इसको हम क्या बोलते हैं ग्लोबिंग तो अब
बात करते हैं ग्लोबिंग ये रहा एक
मिनट ये
रहा ग्लोबिंग इसको हम जो ग्लोबिंग है
टॉपिक है मेरा ये ग्लो
बिंग चलो जो ग्लोबिंग जो आज का मेरा टॉपिक
है नेक्स्ट एंटर करता हूं मैं नेक्स्ट
ओके अब क्या है इट इज आल्सो इट इज
आल्सो नोन एज फाइल नेम एक्सपेंशन फाइल नेम
एक्सपेंशन फाइल नेम एक्सपेंशन भी बोलते
हैं ये काफी यूजफुल और पावरफुल है हमारे
बेस्ट स्क्रिप्टिंग में बेस्ट
स्क्रिप्टिंग में नहीं आप ऑलरेडी इसको यूज
करते हो लेकिन क्या इसको टेक्निकली हम
वर्ड बोलते नहीं है बट क्या है कि उसको हम
ऑलरेडी यूज कर रहे हैं और आप अभी तक अपने
कमांड के अंदर इसको यूज करते भी आए हो ब
भी पता चल जाए चीज क्या हैय ग्लोबिंग अब
ग्लोबिंग होता क्या है कहां से आया इसके
बारे में थोड़ा सा डिस्कस करते हैं ओके
डिकस करेंगे
इट ओरिजनेट्स
फ्रॉम
द
ग्लोब
प्रोग्राम ग्लोब प्रोग्राम जो प्रेजेंट
इन
अर्ली
वर्जन
ऑफ
बेल
लब्स यूनिक्स ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
फ्रॉम 1969 टू
1969 टू 19 1969 से 1975 के बीच में यक्स
का जो प्रोजेक्ट ब लेबोरेटरी के अंदर वही
से वहां से नेट ग्लोब प्रोग्राम था उससे य
ओरिजनेट हुआ है अब यह करता क्या है
बेसिकली
देखो ग्लोब
प्रोग्राम
प्रोग्राम वाज ए
प्रोग्राम ए प्रोग्राम
दैट
वुड ट वुड
रिप्लेस
टेक्स्ट ट वड रिप्लेस टेक्स्ट कंटेनिंग
टी ए आई कंटेनिंग
स्पेशल कंटेनिंग स्पेशल
पैटर्न पैटर्न सिंबल्स
कंटे सिंबल्स
विद
ए लिस्ट
ऑफ फाइल नेम
ट एस मैचेस ट
मैच मैच दोज पैटर्न डट दोज
पैटर्स अब यह होता है देखो अंग्रेजी जो
मैंने लिख दिया आपको शायद समझ में नहीं आई
होगी समझा दूंगा ग्लो प्रोग्राम वा
प्रोग्राम ट वड रिप्लेस टेक्स्ट कंटेनिंग
स्पेशल पैटन सिंबल वि लिस्ट ऑफ फाइल नेम ट
मैचेस दो पैटन अभी देखो आपका हमेशा काम
या तो किसी फाइल को रिप्लेस कर रहे होते
हैं या कोई ना कोई चीजें हम ढूंढ रहे होते
हैं किसी भी प्रोजेक्ट के हिसाब से डिपेंड
करता है प्रोजेक्ट के ऊपर तो अभी एक चीज
बताइए कि आपको अगर प्रोग्राम में कुछ
सर्चिंग करना है या नक् में आपको कुछ
सर्चिंग करना है तो हर एक वर्ड हर एक फाइल
का नाम थोड़ी ना याद रहेगा किसी को भी
नहीं याद रहता ना इवन अगर आपको लोग देखने
हैं तब भी आपको क्या है सारे लोग थो ना
याद रहेंगे आपको नाई मशीन को मशीन को याद
किसी को रहते हां हमें होता है कि अग लोग
मॉनिटरिंग कर रहे हो या कोई प्रोग्राम लिख
रहे हो या कोई टूल्स फाइंड आउट कर रहे हो
आपको कोई वर्ड याद हो कोई फुल वर्ड की
बजाय कोई उसके कैरेक्टर्स याद हो कुछ
लिमिटेड कैरेक्टर्स या कोई एक वर्ड के साथ
आपको आईडिया है कि डॉटी एक्सटी हो सकता है
या एंड में डॉट पीडीएफ हो सकता है या कोई
बाइनरी फाइल है या बस आपको वर्ड याद है
उसके बाद आपको याद नहीं बोला कि हां मुझे
यह वर्ड याद है कि यह नेम का सचिन है फॉर
एग्जांपल
सचिन का कोई वर्ड है उसी को आप ढूंढ रहे
हो तो सचिन नाम है लेकिन उसके पीछे और भी
कुछ भी फाइल हो सकती है हो सकता है सचिन
नाम से कोई फाइल मिली हो ड पीडीएफ हो कोई
बाइनरी फाइल हो कुछ भी हो तो अब आपको
आईडिया नहीं आ रहा कि कौन सी फाइल है तो
वो काम परफॉर्म करने के लिए अब ऐसा तो
नहीं है कि आपको पता नहीं है लेकिन उसके
बाद क्या है यह भी नहीं पता कि उसके बाद
तीन कैरेक्टर है पांच कैरेक्टर है 10
कैरेक्टर है ये दो ही कैरेक्टर है अब ए टू
जड है रो से नाइन है और सिंबल्स भी बच गए
अब आप ऐसा करोगे क्या कि किसी भी कमांड के
साथ वन बाय वन बाय किसी कैरेक्टर को रखोगे
पहले सचिन के साथ ए को रखोगे फिर बी को
रखोगे एंड में फिर सी को रखोगे उसके बाद
डी ई एफ जी ए टू जड रखोगे ओके इनमें से
नहीं मिला उसके बाद ये आप ऐसा खुद तो करने
नहीं चलोगे ना यह काम आप खुद नहीं करोगे
तो यही ची इसी प्रॉब्लम को सॉल्व करने के
लिए ग्लोबिंग का यूज किया जाता है
ग्लोबिंग में क्या करते हो आप जितना वर्ड
आपको याद है उसके बाद क्या करते हो आप कुछ
पैटर्न दे देते हो और वो पैटर्न आप ऑलरेडी
यूज करते हो तो उस पैटर्न को देने के बाद
आपको क्या होता है कि वो पैटर्न ऑटोमेटिक
परफॉर्म करता है कि वो सारी आपका अल्फा
न्यूमेरिकली अपने आप ही उस वहां पर जगह पर
रख के देखता और जो भी उसके साथ मैच करता
है अकॉर्डिंग टू कमांड जिस चीज को फाइंड
आउट करने है और आपकी मशीन में कोई भी फाइल
या डायरेक्टरी में जो भी आपको जहां भी आप
वहां पर आपको मैच करता है और मैच करते ही
आपको क्या करता है आपके स्क्रीन पे उन
सबको क्या कर देता है प्रिंट कर देता है
आपकी स्क्रन के आउटपुट में शो कर देता है
तो इसने वही बोला है वो एक प्रोग्राम था
ग्लो प्रोग्राम भी यही काम करता था
ग्लोबिंग भी यही काम कर रही है उसी से
इसको लिया गया है आप कोई पैटर्न देते हो
सिंबल को और उसके बेसिस पर वो क्या करता
है आपको मैच रिजल्ट को आपके स्क्रीन पे शो
करता है तो बेसिकली क्या है
कि इट
इज
ओनली परफॉर्म्ड इट इज ओनली परफॉर्म ऑन
वर्ड्स ऑन वर्ड्स जो वर्ड्स है ना जो आपका
जो टोकेनाइजेशन के बाद जो वर्ड्स और
ऑपरेटर बनते हैं जो वर्ड्स है उन्हीं के
ऊपर ओनली इसको परफॉर्म किया जाता है ओनली
वर्ड्स के ऊपर इसको परफॉर्म किया जाता है
ग्लोबिंग को सबके ऊपर ग्लोबिंग को परफॉर्म
नहीं किया जाता तो अभी क्या है कि जैसे ही
सेल को वर्ड मिलता है जैसे ही सेल को वर्ड
मिलता है बेस्ट सेल को क्या करता है वो
स्कैन करता है वर्ड्स को वर्ड्स को स्कैन
करता है और उसमें क्या फाइंड आउट करने की
कोशिश करता है उसमें उन पैटर्स को फाइंड
आउट कर कोशिश करता है पैटर्स कौन से कुछ
स्पेशल कैरेक्टर्स है कुछ स्पेशल
कैरेक्टर्स है उन्हीं को क्या करता है
फाइंड आउट करता है कौन-कौन से स्पेशल
कैरेक्टर्स एक तो आपका एस्टिक्स जिसको हम
बोलते हैं स्टार ए कंट्रोल जड यह रहा यह
आपको जिसको हम बोलते बोलते हैं एस्टिक्स
ए एस टी आर आई एस के एस्टिक्स कुछ ऐसा
बोलते हैं एक होता है आपका स्पेशल
क्वेश्चन मार्क आपका यह है एक यह भी क्या
है आपका एक स्पेशल कैरेक्टर यह भी क्या है
क्वेश्चन मार्क एक क्वेश्चन मार्क जो आपका
थर्ड है वो होता है आपका यह ब्रैकेट आपका
ये होता है ब्रैकेट ओपन कर ली अब ओपन
ब्रैकेट प्लस में क्लोज ब्रैकेट यही है
पूरा वैसे स्टार्ट इससे होता है तो ये
क्या करता है जैसे वर्ड दिखता है सेल्स
ग्लोबिंग के लिए स्कैन करता है और जहां
जहां पर जहां जिस वर्ड में ये स्टार
क्वेश्चन मार्क और ये तीन कैरेक्टर देखने
को मिलते हैं ये तीन स्पेशल कैरेक्टर
देखने को मिलते हैं वहीं पर ये ग्लोबिंग
परफॉर्म करता है उसे लगता है कि यहां पर
मुझे ग्लोबिंग परफॉर्म करना है अब एक और
चीज रखना कि ये जो तीनों कैरेक्टर्स है
ना ये तीनों कैरेक्टर्स मैं आपको बता दूं
ये तीनों कैरेक्टर्स अनकोटेड होने चाहिए
ये तीनों तीनों कैरेक्टर्स भी वर्ड के
अंदर अनकोटेड होना चाहिए कोटेड नहीं होना
चाहिए और कोटिंग अगर आपको नहीं पता तो डे
थ्री की क्लास में आप पढ़ सकते हो और आज
जो मैंने शेयर किए नोट्स वहां से आपको पता
चल जाए तो वो कोटेड अनकोटेड होने चाहिए
अनकोटेड आपको पता है जिसका स्पेशल मीनिंग
रिमूव नहीं किया गया हो ओके तो सबसे पहले
अब हम स्क्रीन पर चलते हैं और वन बाय वन
इनके बारे में समझते हैं कि ये कैसे
परफॉर्म होते हैं आपकी किसी भी कमांड्स के
ऊपर तो हम चलते हैं स्क्रीन के ऊपर ये रहा
फॉर एग्जांपल ब एक काम करता हूं य अभी मैं
एल करता हूं तो य मेरा क्या होम
डायरेक्टरी
है स्क्रीन को मैं क्रिएट करता हूं एक ब
कुछ फाइल क्रिएट कर लेता हूं टी य सीच टच
किया मैंने उसके बाद
फाइल देन वन से लेकर फ तक और कुछ फाइल
करना चाहता हूं डटी एक्टी फाइल मैंने
क्रिएट किया है ये फाइल क्रिएट की फ मैं
क्या करहा टच और कुछ फ फाइल कट करना चाहता
हूं फाइल मैंने क्या किया ए के नाम से
फाइल को क्रिएट किया मैंने फाइल ए डॉट टी
एक्सटी के नाम से मैंने फाइल को क्रिएट
किया एक फाइल मैंने क्रिएट की कैपिटल ए बी
सी के नाम से इसको मैंने क्रिएट किया एक
स्मल ए बी सी के नाम से ए बी सी के नाम से
एक फाइल को मैंने क्रिएट किया एक मैंने
क्या कर दिया टूथ के नाम से मैंने फाइल को
क्रिएट किया फाइल टूथ के नाम से मैंने
फाइल को क्रिएट किया उसके बाद एक और फाइल
को मैंने क्रिएट किया नॉर्मल ए बी के नाम
से ए और बी के नाम से मैंने फाइल को कट
किया ए और बी के नाम से मैंने को क्रिएट
कर दिया 1 2 3 4 5 हो गया एक नॉर्मल फाइल
t एक्टी मैंने क्रिएट कर लिया मैं एक और
नॉर्मल क्या फाल t एक नाम से मैंने इतनी
फाइलें क्रिएट कर दिया अगर मैं एलस करके
दिखाऊंगा तो ये फाइल्स मैंने क्रिएट कर दी
है आपको दिखाई दे रही होंगी अब मुझे क्या
करना है मैं सबसे पहले जो ग्लोबिंग पैटर्न
है जो सबसे पहले मैं उसको यूज करके
दिखाऊंगा कौन सा है स्टार एस्टिक्स जिसको
हम बोलते हैं सबसे ज्यादा यूज किया जाता
है सबसे कॉमनली यूज किया जाने वाला
ग्लोबिंग स्पेशल कैरेक्टर है ये और काफी
फ्लेक्सिबल यूज किया जाता है और आपने अभी
तक कई बार यूज किया होगा फॉर एग्जांपल मैं
क्या करता हूं एलस करता हूं एलएस के बाद
अगर मैं क्या करता हूं स्ट्रिक्स दे देता
हूं स्टार दे देता हूं इसका मतलब क्या है
कि अब मुझे कुछ नहीं पता आपको क्या करना
सब स्टार का मतलब ऑल सब कुछ जो भी मिले आप
यहां पर क्या कर करंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी
में करंट वर्किंग डायरेक्ट जो भी कुछ मिले
आप सबको क्या कर दो प्रिंट कर दो अब देखो
सबको इसने क्या कर दिया आपके स्क्रीन के
सामने सब कुछ स्टार डेस्कटॉप डॉक्यूमेंट
डाउनलोड सब कुछ इसने आपके सामने प्रिंट कर
दिया आउटपुट में शो कर दिया फॉर एग्जांपल
मैं क्या चाता हूं मैंने एलस किया देन मैं
क्या कर रहा हूं एस यूज कर रहा हूं डॉट t
एक्सटी मुझे पता है कि मेरी जो फाइल्स है
उनके एंड में टी एक्सटी एक्सटेंशन है
लेकिन ये नहीं पता मुझे कि आगे क्या है आई
डोंट नो कि आगे कुछ भी हो और ऊपर सबसे
बड़ी बात का जो एस्ट्रिक्स है वो लेंथ के
ऊपर डिपेंडेंट नहीं है मतलब लेंथ
स्पेसिफिक नहीं है अब यहां पर क्या ऐसा
नहीं कि एक ही कैरेक्टर को ढूंढेगा नहीं
वनस एक भी हो सकता है 10 5 15 20 25 30
कितना भी हो सकता है लेकिन एंड में डटी
एकटी होना चाहिए फ्रंट में कुछ भी हो हिट
एंटर किया तो इसने देखो फाल t एकटी फाइल 1
23 फाइल 3 फाइल 5 ये सब कुछ इसने आपके
सामने प्रिंट कर दिया चलो इट्स ओके अब मैं
एक काम करता हूं एलस करता हूं एस्टिक्स
यूज करता हूं उसके बाद मैं डॉट पीडीएफ के
नाम से ढूंढता हूं क्या है कोई कोई भी
फाइल नहीं मिली क्योंकि है ही नहीं इसने
आपको सामने शो कर दिया अब फॉर एग्जांपल
मुझे याद है कि फाइल उसका वर्ड है मुझे
पता फाइल वर्ड है उसके बाद एट्रिक्स मैंने
यूज कि मुझे नहीं मालूम उसके बाद क्या
आएगा लेकिन हां एंड में टी एकटी है लेकिन
एंड में t मतलब फाइल स्टार्टिंग
स्टार्टिंग से होना चाहिए लेकिन फाइल के
बाद टूथ 4 कितने भी कैरेक्टर्स हो यह सब
उसको प्रिंट करके दे देगा एनीथिंग ये देखो
अब न टूथ इवन सिंगल फाइल को भी इसने
प्रिंट करके दे दिया अभी फॉर एग्जांपल अगर
आपको ये था आपका एस्टिक्स का अगर ये था
आपका एस का केस ये था आपका एस्टिक्स का
केस अगर आपको इतना याद है कि वन है फाइल
वन है तो ट एंटर देखो न टूथ य दो फाइल
क्रिएट अब ये ए का पता चल गया अब बात करते
हैं हम कौन सा क्वेश्चन मार्क की देखो जो
क्वेश्चन मार्क है और टक्शन में ज्यादा
डिफरेंस नहीं है दोनों के दोनों लेंथ
स्पेसिफिक नहीं है अंतर ये है कि एस्टिक्स
क्या करता है ए ये क्या करता है कि जहां
पर यूज किया था वहां पर ये क्या ये नहीं
देखता कि मुझे एक वर्ड एक ही वर्ड ढूंढना
दो जितने भी वर्ड्स मिलेंगे उस पर्टिकुलर
पैटर्न में सबको मैच कर स्क्रीन पर शो कर
देगा आपको देख लिया फाइल 1tx टी एकड होना
चाहिए फाइल वन आगे होना चाहिए बीच में
कितने भी लेंथ के मिले कैरेक्टर्स टूथ 4
सब कु मिलेगा क्वेश्चन मार्क्स में क्या
है वो लेंथ स्पेसिफिक वो भी नहीं है ऐसा
नहीं कि मुझे कुछ वो ए टू जड अल्फा
न्यूमेरिकल कुछ भी ढूंढेगा बट ओनली एक ही
कैरेक्टर को ढूंढेगा ये ओनली एक ही
कैरेक्टर्स को ढूंढेगा फॉर एग्जांपल मैंने
लिखा एल एस फाइल उसके बाद मैंने लिया
क्वेश्चन मार्क ओनली एक ही कक्टर को
ढूंढेगा ये क्या क्वेश्चन मार्क देन डॉट t
एक्सटी अब देखो अभी ओनली ट 3 4 5 और ए को
ही ढूंढा ए सी टूथ किसी को नहीं ढूंढा ओके
अब मैं चाहता हूं नहीं मुझे दो कैरेक्टर्स
को ढूंढना है ओके डबल यूज किया तो अभी
ओनली फाइ एड अब ओनली वन वाले को प्रिंट
करेगा नहीं मतलब जितने हमने क्वेश्चन
मार्क को यूज किया उतने ही ं उतनी ही वाली
फाइल को ढूंढेगा उससे ना तो आगे ना कम ना
ज्यादा अब मैंने यहां पर तीन यूज कर लिए
तो ओनली थर्ड वाली ही टूथ ए बी सी और स्मल
ए बी सीय तीन ही फाइल को ढूंढ करके दिखाया
इसने यह था आपका क्वेश्चन मार्क अब बात
करते हैं हम
ब्रैकेट्स की बात करते हैं ब्रैकेट क्या
है जो मैंने दिखाया था यह वाला जो हम चलते
हैं स्क्रीन के ऊपर यह रहा ये रहा आपको
देख रहा होगा य ब्रैकेट एक
मिनट ये रहा जो ब्रैकेट दिखाई दे रहा है
यह क्या है आपका लेंथ स्पेसिफिक है लेंस
स्पेसिफिक कैसे है मतलब कि इसके अंदर
जितने भी आप कैरेक्टर्स दोगे सिर्फ उन्हीं
को मैच करेगा ये अल्फा न्यूमेरिकल सबको
नहीं देखेगा स्टार और क्वेश्चन मार्क की
तरह नहीं इस ब्रैकेट के अंदर इसी के अंदर
जितने भी लेंथ ऑफ कैरेक्टर्स दोगे आप उन
सभी को ही ढूंढेगा उसके अलावा किसी को
नहीं ढूंढेगा मैच करेगा और ओनली एक ही
कैरेक्टर को मैच करेगा कैसे मैंने एलएस
लिखा फाइल लिखा उसके बाद मैं क्या कर रहा
हूं ये ब्रैकेट देन इसके बाद मैं ढूंढ रहा
हूं ए बी और ए बी सी और ड t एकटी अब ये
ओनली देखो ओनली ए को ही प्रिंट किया
क्योंकि ए ही है बी हमारी फाइल ही नहीं
मैंने यहां पर अगर टूथ लिखा मैंने टूथ तो
हिट एंटर देखो नटू और थ को क्या मतलब एक
ही कैरेक्टर्स को ही इसने प्रिंट किया
आपके स्क्रीन सामने क्योंकि करता काम
क्वेश्चन मार्क की तरह है लेकिन क्या है
ये लेंथ स्पेसिफिक है अगर मैंने यहां पर
लिखा ए ए भी होना चाहिए ए बी सी में से
कुछ भी हो तो टटर देखो वन 2 3 और ए वाली
फाइल को इसने प्रिंट कर दिया तो ये ओनली
स्पेसिफिक लेंथ स्पेसिफिक एक्टर उसके बाद
मैंने एक और क्या कर दिया यहां पर एक और
लगा दिया अब मैं दो ओनली दो कैरेक्टर्स को
उसमें भी क्या टूथ होने चाहिए देखो अब है
ही नहीं ऐसी कोई फाइल ऐसी कोई फाइल है ही
नहीं चलो अब मैं यहां पर क्या करता हूं ए
बी सी लिख देता हूं टटर ए बी सी है ए बी
है सी नहीं है ए बी हां ए बी वाली फाइल को
इसने ढूंढ के दिखा दिया क्योंकि दो ही
कैरेक्टर्स में अगर मैं एक कम कर देता हूं
यहां पर ए बी सी उसके बाद बंद कर देता हूं
देखो अभी भी नहीं है
क्योंकि अब मैं क्या करता हूं यहां पर टू
ी उसके बाद ए बी सी हीट एंटर ये रहा ए बी
सी स्मल ए बी सी को ही प्रिंट किया
क्योंकि एक ही फाइल जिसमें तीन कैरेक्टर
तीन कैरेक्टर है ए बी सी क्योंकि इसमें
कैपिटल वाले है नहीं इसमें कैपिटल वाले है
नहीं बस इसमें इसमें कैपिटल प्लस में सभी
कैरेक्टर्स को मैंने दे दिया आप इस तरीके
से मेंशन करते हैं अदर वाइज कैसे ढूंढ
सकते हो एलएस किया आपने फाइल लिखा उसके
बाद ऐसे भी यूज कर सकते हो आप इसके अंदर
आपको लिखा अगर मुझे ए से लेकर एड अगर कू
दिया है ए से क्यू देखेगा
सीक्वेंस होना चाहिए ऐसे नहीं कि य उसके
बाद कथ है एक सीक्वेंस में जाना चाहिए
विदाउट सीक्वेंस काम नहीं करेगा य टी एक्
ऐसे उसके एटर कर दिया बस एक ही है आप चाहो
तो जीरो से ना भी दे सकते हो जीड ना ना य
पर दे सकते हो ंटर कर दिया तो ये रहा इसने
ऐसे प्रिंट आपके स्क्रीन के सामने शो कर
दिया आप चाहो तो ऐसे भी कर सकते
हो जीरोड ना ये रहा उसके बाद दो ही उसके
बाद जीरो ड ना ये रहा ट एंटर टूथ को इसने
आप स्कन अब ऐसा नहीं है किय करंट वर्किंग
डाई के साथ ही काम करता आप चाहो तो कहीं
पर भी सर्च कर सकते हो इसको फॉर एग्जांपल
मैंने क्या किया एलस किया और मैं क्या कर
रहा हूं रूट के अंदर और मुझे नहीं पता
उसके बाद मैं सारी फाइल को देखना चाहता
हूं रोट के अंदर मैं सारी फाइल्स को देखना
चाहता हूं ये रहा ये टटर देखो जितने भी
रूट के अंदर सब कु इसने क्या कर दिया आपको
सब स्क्रीन के सामने प्रिंट कर दिया रूट
के अंदर जो भी कुछ था बहुत कुछ है सब कुछ
इसने आपकी स्क्रीन के सामने शो कर दिया था
दिस इ द पावर ऑफ ग्लोबिंग ये हमारा जो
टॉपिक था ग्लोबिंग का था यही हमारा जो
टॉपिक है ग्लोबिंग था तो ग्लोबिंग का
टॉपिक हमारा खत्म हो गया होगा प्लीज जो भी
अभी अवेलेबल है जो भी हमारे इसमें चैट में
है प्लीज यस नो बताइए सबको समझ में आया या
नहीं आया ग्लोबिंग का फिर नेक्स्ट टॉपिक
चलते हैं हम कोट रिमूवल
पर
बता दीजिए
दीप्ति और अली
मिया मिस्टर
3 बताइए प्लीज आप लोग जो अवेलेबल हो ना
अभी प्लीज मुझे बता दीजिए कि आप सबको समझ
में आ रहा है या नहीं आ रहा फटाफट हम क्या
करते कोट रिमूव करेंगे रीडायरेक्शन ऑलरेडी
हम पढ़ चुके हैं है मैं आपको हिंट दे
दूंगा कहां से आपको देखना
है बताइए जल्दी से बताइए चैट
में अगर नहीं आया तो रिपीट कर दूं कोई बात
नहीं है आप मुझसे पूछ सकते हो
दोबारा नो
इशू ओके थैंक यू तो हम बात करते हैं कोट
मोल के बारे में कोटरी मोल क्या होता है
अब देखो स्टेप फोर आ गया हमारा कोट रिमूवल
स्टेप फोर हमारा अब आ गया कोट रिमूवल का
स्टेप
फोर य बात करने वाले कोट रिमूवल
और कोट
रिमूवल नाम में य इसके वसे आपको समझ में आ
जाना चाहिए बट मैं आपको बता दूंगा कोट
रिमोल होता क्या है देखो क्या है क्या
आपको आपने कोटिंग पढ़ा है आपने कोटिंग
पढ़ा था की कोटिंग क्या करता है स्पेशल
मीनिंग रिमूव करता है और आपको पता है कि
तीन टाइप्स के कोड्स होते हैं दे ी टाइप्स
ऑफ को कौन कन से होते तीन टाइप्स के को
आपको रेडी पता है एक तो कोट होता है
बैकलेस
के एस एल ए एस
एक तोय होता है बैकलेस आपको पता कौन सा
होता है य रहा बैकलेस य रहा एक तोय होता
है नहीं बक
स्लस यह होता ना बक स्लेस नेक्स्ट सेकंड
होता आपका जो है सिंगल
कोट
सिंगल सिंगल कोट यह
रहा सिंगल कोट एक जो होता आपका डबल
कोट ये होता है
डबल कोट ये होता है आपका डबल
कोट ये रहा तीन टाइप्स के कोट होते हैं
अभी क्या है आप ये पहले बात अगर आपको याद
हो अगर नहीं भी याद हो कोई बात नहीं है हम
मैं आपको याद दिला देता हूं कि हम कोटिंग
यूज क्यों करते थे कोटिंग को हम यूज ही
क्यों कर रहे थे देखो कोटिंग को यूज करते
थे किसी भी कैरेक्टर का स्पेशल मीनिंग
रिमूव करने के लिए तभी हमें कोटिंग को यूज
करने की जरूरत पड़ती थी अदर वाइज हमें
कोटिंग की जरूरत नहीं थी क हम नहीं चाहते
थे कि जो उसका स्पेशल मीनिंग है उस पट
कक्टर का वो वहां पर परफॉर्म हो इसलिए हम
कोटिंग को यूज कर देते लेकिन एक बात बताइए
मुझे जब किसी भी कैरेक्टर का स्पेशल
मीनिंग ज रिमूव हो ही गया तो मुझे उसके
बाद उस उन कोट्स की उस सिंगल कोट की डबल
कोट के बैक स्लेस की क्या जरूरत है नहीं
है सिंपली मुझे जरूरत नहीं है इसलिए हम
क्या करते हैं जब किसी भी कैक्टस का एक
बार कोट कोटिंग हो गया उसके बाद हम क्या
करते हैं उनको रिमूव कर देते हैं बट वो
रिमूव करने के लिए कंडीशन के साथ काम करती
है वो कंडीशन क्या है मैं बताता हूं वो
किस कंडीशन पे कोट रिमूव होता है स्टेप
देखो
ड्यूरिंग कोट
रिमूवल ड्यूरिंग कोट रिमूवल द सेल
रिमूवस ल अनकोटेड
यह भी अनकोटेड होने चाहिए ल अनकोटेड
बैक
लेसेस अनकोटेड बैकलेस सिंगल
कोर्स
सिंगल सिंगल कोट्स एंड सिंगल कोट्स एंड
डबल कोट
कैरेक्टर डबल कोट कैरेक्टर्स
ट
डंट ट डंट
रिजल्ट रिजल्ट फम ए सेल
एक्सपेंशन सेल एक्सपेंशन
देखो क्या है इसने य बोला कि ड्यूरिंग कोट
रिमूवल द सेल रिमूव ल अनकोटेड बैक स्लस
सिंगल कोट डबल कोट कक्टर ट ड नॉट रिजल्ट
फ्रॉम सेल एक्सपेंशन इसने बोला है कि एक
तो जो आपके जब कोट रिमूव होता है तो एक तो
जो बैक स्लस है सिंगल कोट डबल कोट वो क्या
होने चाहिए अनकोटेड होने चाहिए सारे सारे
क्या होने चाहिए अन कोटेड होने चाहिए देखो
बिल्कुल ध्यान
से और सारे सारे क्या होने चाहिए कोटेड
होना चाहिए दूसरा दूसरी कंडीशन क्या है वो
किसी भी सेल एक्सपेंशन चाहे वो ब्रेस
एक्सपेंशन हो चाहे वो आपका पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन हो ल् एक्सपेंशन हो कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन हो अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन हो या
ग्लोबिंग हो वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग हो इनका जो
भी आउटपुट है जो भी सेल एक्सपेंशन जितने
पड़े उनका रिजल्ट नहीं होना चाहिए मतलब
कोट रिमूव होगा बट एक तो किनके ऊपर होगा
एक तो वो अनकोटेड बैक स्लस सिंगल कोट डबल
कोट होने चाहिए दूसरा वो किसी भी सेल
एक्सपेंशन का रिजल्ट नहीं होने चाहिए वो
किसी भी सेल एक्सपेंशन का रिजल्ट नहीं
होने चाहिए फॉर एग्जांपल मैं आपको दिखाता
हूं कैसे मेरा कहने का मतलब क्या है फॉर
एग्जांपल मैंने लिखा एकको एकको डॉलर एकको
डॉलर होम मैंने लिखा एक डॉलर होम अभी तक
मैंने इसमें कोटिंग यूज किया मैंने बैक
स्ल यूज किया अब ये क्या है कोटिंग है अभी
यहां पर मैंने कोटिंग यूज किया अभी हिट
एंटर कर दिया तो डलर होम एज इट इज आ गया
देखो जो बैलेस य पर क्या है अनकोटेड है
क्यक बैक्स लेस य पर क्या है अनकोटेड हमने
य पर कोट को यूज नहीं किया है क्योंकि कोट
रिमूव हो गया इधर अगर ये अनकोटेड नहीं
होता तो प्रॉब्लम होती एक तो अनकोटेड है
दूसरा किसी भी सेल एक्सपेंशन का आउटपुट
नहीं है एक दूसरा एग्जांपल है एक को किया
मैंने उसके बाद मैंने क्या सिंगल कोट के
अंदर मैंने लिखा बैकलेस और डॉलर होम आपके
मैंने लिखा डॉलर होम मैंने एज इट लिखा अब
फिट एंटर कर दिया अ ये ऐसा आया आउटपुट ऐसा
क्यों आया क्योंकि भैया जो आपका जो बैक्स
लेस है यह क्या है कोटेड है अनकोटेड नहीं
है इसलिए आया क्योंकि कोट रिमूवल के टाइम
पर ये सिंगल कोट तो रिमूव हो गए तो अभी यह
क्या हो गया कोटेड हो गया इसलिए एज इट इज
आपका आउटपुट स्क्रीन पर शो हो गया कोट
रिमल के दौरान यह था फॉर एग्जांपल मैं
क्या करता हूं एक पाथ वेरिएबल है मैं इधर
क्या करता हूं एक वेरिएबल
क्या करता नेम नेम वेरिएबल इक्वल साइन
दिया मैंने उसके अंदर मैं स्टोर किया डबल
कोट देन उसके बाद सी ड्राइव उसके
बाद कॉलन देन उसके बाद यूजर यूजर्स उसके
बाद मैंने
लिखा सचिन उसके बाद मैंने लिखा डॉक्यूमेंट
डी ओ सी यू एम ई एनटी डॉक्यूमेंट और मैंने
क्या कर इसको ट एंटर कर दिया अब मैं एकको
करता हूं अबको करता हूं और डॉलर डॉलर क्या
करता हूं नेम करता हूं आप लोग मुझे यह
बताइए इसका रिजल्ट क्या आएगा इसका रिजल्ट
क्या आएगा अगर आप लोगों को समझ में आ रहा
हो तो इसका रिजल्ट क्या आएगा सिंपल है
देखो भैया सबसे पहले यह है इसका होगा कोट
रिमूवल इसका होगा कोट रिमूवल क्यों होगा
क्योंकि यह अपने आप में एक अलग कमांड है
तो यहां से क्या कर दिया ये जो डबल कोट्स
थे जो डबल कोट थे रिमूव हो गए तो आउटपुट
में क्या बचा अगर मैं आपको इसको एक होम को
क्या कर देता हूं अगर मैं ये कर देता हूं
अभी कमेंट कर देता हूं टटर करता हूं ये
यहां पर फ यहां पर क्या हो गया यहां बच
गया ये सी यूजर इतना बच गया बस इतना बच
गया अब ये यहां आपका आके इसको रिप्लेस कर
देगा ये क्या कर दे इसको रिप्लेस कर दिया
कैसे लिखा जाएगा ये ये आएगा
एकको उसके बाद डॉलर नेम की जगह क्या आ रहा
है सी ये रहा उसके
बाद यूजर्स उसके बाद सचिन
सचिन इसने इसको ऐसे रिप्लेस कर दिया
ना डॉक्यूमेंट डॉक्यूमेंट ये रहा ये इसको
ऐसे रिप्लेस कर रहा है जब आप कमांड ऐसे
लिख रहे हो ना अब अगर आप ऐसे लिख रहे हो
एकको और डॉलर और नेम लिख रहे हो इसको क्या
कर रहा है ये कैसे रिप्लेस कर रहा है इसको
ऐसे रिप्लेस कर रहा है एक डॉलर और इसका
आउटपुट फिर हमें क्या आएगा अब आपको दिखाता
हूं मैं ट एंटर अब मैं एकको करता हूं जब
मैं फिर उसके बाद अगर डॉलर मैं क्या करता
हूं नेम करता हूं तो अभी मुझे यह बताइए अब
हिट एंटर कर दिया लेकिन आउटपुट ऐसा क्यों
आया यूजर था लेकिन अभी भी आउटपुट डॉलर नेम
था ये रहा एससीआर यूजर्स कहां गया
भैया कुछ गड़बड़ हो गया इट्स ओके चलो डॉलर
नेम अब तो आउटपुट ऐसा क्यों आया भैया
आउटपुट ऐसा क्यों आया क्योंकि देखो आपने
बोला था कि सर
कोट रिमूवल में यहां तो कोट रिमूव हो गए
बट सर ये य क्यों नहीं ये क्यों नहीं हुआ
ये ये यहां पर और ये यहां पर ट रिमूवल हुआ
क्यों नहीं डलर नेम यूजर्स आना चाहिए
भाई कुछ इशू है ग गिल चाहिए बट ऐसे आएगा
आउटपुट आपका ऐसे ही आएगा ये क्योंकि कारण
ये है मैंने आपको बोला था जब कोट रिमूव
होता है पहली बात तो क्या है जो आपके
सिंगल कोट डबल कोट बैक
स्लैश अनकोटेड होने चाहिए दूसरा वो किसी
भी सेल एक्सपेंशन का आउटपुट नहीं होने
चाहिए अभी यहां पर क्या है यह तो आउटपुट
है ना यहां पर ऐसे देखो ऐसे आ गया ना ये
आपको दिखाई दे रहा हो यहां पर सी यूजर
सचिन डॉक्यूमेंट ऐसे दिखाई दे रहा है अब
यहां पर तो इसपे कैसे को क्योंकि ये किसका
आउटपुट है इसका जो वेरिएबल है वेरिएबल है
यहां पर क्या हुआ पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन
परफॉर्म हुआ जब पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन
परफॉर्म होता है उसका आउटपुट य रिप्लेस कर
दिया इसलिए इसके ऊपर कोटिंग वैसे ही कोट
रिम इस परफॉर्म नहीं हो इसलिए एज इट इज
आपका आउटपुट में शो हो रहा है ये था आपका
कोट रिमूवल का टॉपिक कोट रिमूवल ऐसे ही
काम करता है कि कोट रिमूवल काम इन दो
कंडीशन के बेस पर ही कोट रिमूवल होता है
ओके समझ में आया मुझे बताइए फटाफट लास्ट
बच गया
आज ये आपका कोट रिमूवल जो आपका नेक्स्ट बच
गया आपका जो रीडायरेक्शन जो आपका स्टेप
फाइव है रीडायरेक्शन का ये रहा बात करते
हैं हम स्टेप
फाइव
स्टेप फाइव
रीडायरेक्शन रीडायरेक्शन अभी एक बार क्या
हो गया जब एक बार टोकेनाइजेशन होगा कमांड
को आइडेंटिफिकेशन
परफॉर्म कर दिया गया है सेल एक्सशन
परफॉर्म कर दिया कोट रिमूव कर दिया गया तो
उसके बाद भैया ये चीज डिसाइड होगी ना कि
भैया जो भी मेरा हमने क्या कर दिया कमांड
ली थी जो भी स्क्रिप्ट रन की थी उसका
आउटपुट कहां जाना है उसका जो आउटपुट जो
रिजल्ट है क्या किसी फाइल में जाएगा या
किसी
वो टर्मिनल प जाएगा या किसी दूसरी कमांड
का इनपुट बनेगा ये सारी चीजें डिसेंड करती
या कोई एरर आई तो वो एरर भी कहीं आउटपुट
में शो होनी चाहिए या किसी फाइल में
डायरेक्ट होगी कहां जाएगा ये सारे डिसाइड
कहां पर होंगे चार स्टेप परफॉर्म कर लिए
लेकिन ये डिसीजन तो कहीं पर होगा ना ये
डिसीजन होता है आपका रीडायरेक्शन के अंदर
रीडायरेक्शन आपको पता है हम कैसे यूज करते
हैं तीन टाइप्स के होते हैं बेसिकली आपको
अगर आईडिया नहीं है तो मैं आपको बता देता
हूं बट मैं आपको हिंट दे दूंगा कि आपको
कहां से पढ़ना है मैं फुल क्योंकि एक अपने
आप में बहुत बड़ा टॉपिक है और ये मैं
ऑलरेडी पढ़ा चुका हूं देखो रीडायरेक्शन के
लिए एक तो होता है आपका एक होता है एसटीडी
इन होता है स्टैंडर्ड इन जिसको हम बोलते
हैं स्टैंडर्ड इनपुट इसको हम बोलते हैं एस
टी ए एन डी ए आर डी स्टैंडर्ड इनपुट इसको
हम बोलते हैं स्टैंडर्ड इनपुट ए एसटीडी इन
ओके एक होता आपका एसटीडी आउट स्टैंडर्ड
आउटपुट जिसको हम बोलते
हैं स्टैंडर्ड
आउटपुट एक होता आपका स्टैंडर्ड आउटपुट और
आपका होता है एसटीडी एरर
एसटीडी
एसटीडी होता
आपका एसटीडी एरर ई आर आर जिसको हम बोलते
हैं स्टैंडर्ड एरर यह तीन ही होते है
डायरेक्शन
में एस टी ए एन डी ए आर डी स्टैंडर्ड एरर
कि यहां पर डिसी हो था कि जो मेरा इनपुट
है वो कीबोर्ड से लिया जाएगा या किसी फाइल
का फाइल से लिया जाएगा या किसी कमांड का
आउटपुट मेरा इनपुट बनेगा आउटपुट क आउटपुट
कहां पर जाएगा और एरर आए तो कहां पर जाएगा
ये तीनों टॉपिक्स मैं आपको ऑलरेडी बता
चुका हूं तो यहां पर होता है रीडायरेक्शन
कि वो आउटपुट जो मेरा आया उसका जो रिजल्ट
आया वो कहां पर जाएगा फाइल में का इनपुट
जाएगा टर्मिनल पर आएगा यह डिसीजन स्टेप
फाइव में होता है और स्टेप फाइव का डिसीजन
लेने के बाद फिर क्या होता है
आपका एग्जीक्यूशन होता है उसका
एग्जीक्यूशन आपको आउटपुट आपके स्क्रीन पर
सामने दिखाई देता है किसी फाइल में जाता
है सेव होता है या किसी का इनपुट बन जाता
है यह थे आपके पांचों स्टेप हा अगर आपको
रीडायरेक्शन पढ़ना है व बहुत ही ज्यादा
डिटेल्स में जानना है कि डायरेक्शन कैसे
काम करता है बहुत ही ज्यादा डिटेल्स में
सीखना है तो आपको क्या करना है आपको जाना
है डेनिक्स के के
youtube4 प्लेलिस्ट करना है देन ये डे
नंबर थ्री और फोर्थ डे नंबर फोर्थ है ये
रहा इसमें आपका अगर ये क्लिक करोगे ये देख
ये आपका इनपुट आउटपुट डायरेक्शन के ऊपर ये
पूरा का पूरा फुल डिटेल में पूरी डिटेल
में आपको परफॉर्म किया गया कि इनपुट
आउटपुट रीडायरेक्शन कैसे परफॉर्म होगा ये
रीडायरेक्शन का कांसेप्ट
पूरा डायरेक्शन कांसेप्ट है और काफी डीप
कांसेप्ट है कि पूरा बैकग्राउंड नॉलेज है
एक बीटेक लेवल का कांसेप्ट है यह कांसेप्ट
अग क्लियर हो गया तो आपको लाइफ में कभी भी
कहीं भी प्रॉब्लम नहीं होने वाली तो यहां
से आपको क्या करना है डे फोर पर जाके इस
कांसेप्ट को क्लियर करना है अगर आपको
रीडायरेक्शन समझ में नहीं आ रहा है तो
यहां तक का था हमारा जो टॉपिक था आज का
खत्म होगा तो अभी तक किसी को कुछ भी समझ
में नहीं आया अगर किसी को कोई डाउट है कुछ
पूछना है तो मुझसे पूछ सकता
है नो नो नो नो नो नो यह लास्ट लेक्चर
नहीं है यह तो अभी स्टार्टिंग है भैया अभी
क्लास 10 आई है 20 प्लस 20 नहीं है तो 30
प्लस जाएंगी वीडियो 30 से भी ज्यादा
जाएंगी मुझे जहां तक लगता है कि 50 तक
जाएंगी जहां तक लगता है मुझे पता है 50
लेक्चर तक जाएगा क्योंकि यह तो अभी तक तो
बेच स्टार्ट ही नहीं हुआ अभी बेच का बेसिक
कांसेप्ट क्लियर कर रहा हूं आप लोगों का
कि बेस काम कैसे करता है कमांड लाइन के
ऊपर बस वो हुआ है नेक्स्ट एक क्लास है
इसको मैं रिवीजन होगा पूरा कि बेस प्रोसेस
कैसे करता है प्रैक्टिकली रिवीजन होगा मैं
आपको फुल कमांड्स के ऊपर दिखाऊंगा देन
उसके नेक्स्ट क्लास में आपका फिर स्टार्ट
होगा असली लड़ाई कि स्क्रिप्ट कैसे बनेगी
लॉजिक उसके बाद फिर लॉजिक के बाद आपको लूप
कैसे लगाने हैं स्टेटमेंट कैसे यूज करनी
है ऑटोमेशन कैसे परफॉर्म करने हैं और हर
एक उसके साथ उसके साथ क्या ना कांसेप्ट के
साथ आपका एक प्रोजेक्ट जुड़ा होगा
छोटे-छोटे प्रोजेक्ट जो आपको खुद से
परफॉर्म करने होंगे नहीं समझ में आएगा तो
मैं आपको परफॉर्म करवा दूंगा बट उसके बाद
लास्ट में जो फिनिश हो जाए उसके बाद हम
कुछ बड़े प्रोजेक्ट्स बनाएंगे दो से चार
जो आपको काफी यूजफुल रहेंगे इवन नक् एडमिन
हो बग बाउंट हंटर हो कोई भी हो सबको
आईडिया मिल जाएगा कि कैसे मुझे प्रोजेक्ट
को बनाना है कैसे बेस्ट स्क्रिप्टिंग करनी
है और काफी मेरी कैसे साइबर सिक्योरिटी
में वो हेल्प करेगी ओके तो पली ये आपका पा
मिनट का डाउट सेशन है आप लोग मुझसे 5 मिनट
में कोई भी डाउट्स है रिलेटेड टू कांसेप्ट
कुछ भी आप मुझसे पूछ सकते हो रिलेटेड टू
तो 5 मिनट में कुछ भी पूछ सकते हो अभी
जिसका फर्स्ट डे है आज क्लास का डे डे वन
है तो आपको क्या करना है कि जैसे जैसे
मौका पुरानी क्लास को रिवीजन कर लीजिए और
टे ग्रा पर चैनल पर जाना है आपको वहां से
टेलीग्राम ग्रुप को जवाइन कर लीजिए ओके टे
ग्रा चैनल को आपका क्या करना है जवाइन कर
लीजिए उसके बाद आपको सारे अपडेशन सब कुछ
वहीं पर मिल जाएगा फ्यूचर अपडेट भी वहीं
पर मिलते हैं और आपको लेक्चर अच्छा लगा तो
लाइक सब्सक्राइब और कमेंट करना प्लीज मत
भूलिए वो मेरे लिए बहुत माने रखता मेरे
नहीं सबके लिए मायने रखता है ग सर्विस आई
हैव कम फर्स्ट
फय या या या कोई इशू नहीं है यह कोई
प्रोग्राम ही नहीं है स्क्रिप्टिंग
लैंग्वेज है बट क्या है कि एक बेसिक
कांसेप्ट सबका सेम ही रहता है बस सिंटेक्स
चेंज हो जाता है नो इशू आप बैच सीख सकते
हो कोई इशू नहीं है आपको डे वन ला लाइव
सेशन में आप चलते रहिए और उसके बाद क्या
करना आपको जैसे जैसे बीच में टाइम मिलता
है लेक्चर कोई भी बड़ा नहीं है 35 टू 30
मिनट का लेक्चर है हर एक क्लास का उसको आप
इजली रिवीजन कर सकते हो तीन दिन में आसानी
से देख सकते हो नोट्स आपको धीरे-धीरे मिल
रहे हैं मैं अपने मीडियम के
जो मीडियम है मीडियम वेबसाइट है वहां पर
आपके नोट्स बना के आपको शेयर करता रहूंगा
आपको ग्रुप में मिलते रहेंगे नो इशू नोट्स
भी आपको मिलते रहेंगे लेकिन साथ के साथ आप
प्रैक्टिस करते रहिए अभी तक तो प्रैक्टिस
करने लायक कुछ भी नहीं है कांसेप्ट है बस
आप कांसेप्ट को समझना है जस्ट फिनिश ट
इतना ही है नेक्स्ट एक वीडियो में पूरा
कांसेप्ट हम रिवीजन करेंगे तो प्लीज आप
लोगों से रिक्वेस्ट ये करता हूं कि अगर आज
फर्स्ट डे क्लास और ऐसा समझ के मत छोड़ के
जाइए क्लास को कि सर नो नो नो नो अब मुझे
समझ में नहीं आ रहा नहीं मेरी क्लासेस ऐसी
होती है कि आप जिस दिन बैठ के जो सा
कांसेप्ट करोगे ना उस दिन आपको समझ में
आएगा ही आएगा प्रीवियस डिपेंड करता है
लेकिन बहुत कम करता है क्योंकि मैं
प्रीवियस साथ के साथ को बता देता हूं हिंट
दे देता हूं प्रीवियस हमने क्या पढ़ा है
उसके बाद आप जाकर उस चीज को सीख सकते हो
मेरी क्लासेस में ऐसा ही होता है तो आपको
एक काम करना है अभी पा मिनट आप मुझसे कोई
भी डाउट पूछ सकते हैं अगर कोई भी डाउट है
तो चैट सेशन में पूछिए और उसके बाद हम
सेशन एंड करेंगे और डोंट वरी सून ही हम
कुछ एक ऐसा इंटरेस्टिंग स्टार्ट करने वाले
हैं कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग धमाकेदार सबके लिए
इंटरेस्टिंग खासर साइबर सिक्यूरिटी वालों
के लिए तो बहुत ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग है
डोंट वरी और जल्दी आपको पता चल जाएगा तो
आप भी कोई भी डाउट पूछ सकते
हो
और यह मत समझिए ए बेटिंग बेटिंग
स्टार्टिंग आ
है अभी तो इंटरेस्टिंग रेस्टिंग लेक्चर
आएंगे इतने इंटरेस्टिंग लेक्चर आएंगे कि
आप सोच नहीं सकते इतने इंटरेस्टिंग लेक्चर
आएंगे मजा आएगा आपको सच में ही मजा आएगा
कि आप लोग कुछ काम कर रहे हो रियल में
आपको खुद के टूल्स बनाने होंगे ना आपको बस
लॉजिक लगाना है दिमाग में आईडिया लेक आना
और
आजनो आज लास्ट सेशन नहीं है नो नो
नो
नहीं नो लास्ट सेशन लास्ट सेशन है नहीं
अभी तो स्टार्ट सेक्शन वन हुआ है एक
प्रकार से चैप्टर हुभ तो बहुत बड़ा है बस
क्योंकि मैं लास्ट सेशन सेशन में कंप्लीट
करवा सकता था आपको बट मैं आप लोगों को इस
तरीके से समझाऊ कि
आपको हा आप ट की आ में द आपको सिंपली क्या
करना ना आपको अगर ट की प्रैक्टिस की ब
सेटस कर लीजिए आपको अच्छा रहेगा
आपको सिंपली क्या करना है रेड हैट प जाना
है डट आ आर रेड हैट ना आईओ डाउनलोड प जाना
है और सिंपली आपको क्या करना है सॉफ्टवेयर
डाउनलोड सेंटर पर जाना है यहां पर आप क्या
कर सकते हो डाउनलोड कर सकते हो देखो
य ड इंटरप्राइज लिनेक्स आपको क्या करना है
इधर जाना है क्लिक करना है नेक्स्ट उससे
पहले आपको क्या करना होगा रेड प अपना
अकाउंट बनाना होगा
अकाउंट बनाने के बाद आपको क्या है कि वन
ईयर का एक्सेस मिलता है ट्रायल सेशन पे आप
इसको यूज कर सकते हो उसके बाद आओ इमेज
आपको डाउनलोड करने के लिए दे दी जाएगी आप
आओ इमेज को डाउनलोड कर सकते हो बट मैं
आपको बोलूंगा कि रेट की बजाय आप सेंटोस
यूज कीजिए बिल्कुल ओपन सोर्स है फ्री है
ना ही कुछ करना इसमें क्या है कि पैकेजेस
का बहुत इशू आपको पैकेज कन्फर करने होंगे
वो करने होंगे और अदर वाइज आपको क्या है
लोकल रे रेप को कन्फर करना होगा ये सारी
प्रॉब्लम्स आएंगी बट आपको सबसे बेस्ट
सोल्यूशन है आपके पास मैं आपको बता देता
हूं अल्टरनेट है
सेंट सेंट ओस इसी का भाई है बिल्कुल सेंट
ओस ना लेटेस्ट है जो सेंटस ना जाना है
यहां पर सिंपली क्लिक करना है ये रहा
फर्स्ट प क्लिक करना है सेंटस पे देन आपको
जाना है ये
रहा इधर नहीं है दिस इ रंग ये रहा डाउनलोड
प जाना है डाउनलोड पर क्लिक करना है ओ टम
प करना आपको सेटस ओम ना और एक्स 8664 पर
जैसे ही क्लिक करोगे ये देखो यहां पर
डाउनलोड होना स्टार्ट हो गया मेरा इस मैं
अभी इसको पॉज कर रहा हूं क्योंकि मेरे पास
ऑलरेडी है इस तरीके से डाउनलोड करो से ओस
बिल्कुल डेटो कॉपी है किसका रेड हैड का तो
आपको अगर रेड की प्रैक्टिस करनी है तो
सारी कमांड रेड की इस भी चलती है तो इस पर
प्रैक्टिस कर बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ ओपन सोर्स
है इस पर आपको ना रे कन्फर करनी कुछ करनी
आपकी अच्छे से प्रैक्टिस हो जाएगी बिल्कुल
रेट नहीं नहीं नहीं सेंड
कोई बेहतर नहीं है सेंटस ओनली फ क्लाइंट
सर्वर्स के सर्वर्स पर्पस के लिए सेंटस
सेंटस बेटर नहीं है नो सेंटस में कोई भी
टूल्स आपको कुछ नहीं मिलने वाले कमांड
चेंज हो जाती है काली द फोर साइबर
सिक्योरिटी प टेस्टर आल्सो पैट ओसबी आपका
पन टेस्टर के लिए है बट रेड रेट है जो
इंडस्ट्री लेवल के है ये ये सर्वर्स है
एक्चुअल में सर्वर जहां पर आपकी वेबसाइट
हो होती है जहां पर आपके काम होते हैं ये
वो सर्वर्स इंडस्ट्री सर्वर है इंडस्ट्री
में यूज किए जाते हैं तो यहां पर कोई भीय
आप अगर आप चाहते हो कि खुद का कुछ सर्वर
बनाना या खुद का कुछ ओस के साथ कुछ करना
चाहता है कि बिल्कुल आपको डेन को यूज करना
है नहीं रेट के ऊपर खुद बनाना चाहते हो तो
उस पर्पस से आप इसको कर सकते हो अदर वाइज
एज साइबर सिक्योरिटी इंजन नॉट रिक्वायर्ड
रेट आपको बस नॉलेज परपस चाहिए क्योंकि
आपको जब अटैक करने के लिए जो मिलते हैं
सामने जो मशीने मिलती है वो रेट की मिलती
है एक्सल कई बार आपको कमांड सारी चलती है
कोई भी कमांड चेंज नहीं होती बस जो पैकेज
डाउनलोड करने की कमांड है वही हो अरवाज 99
पर कमांड कमांड सेम होती है और कुछ
पूछिए अमित रावत कोर्स का ड्यूरेशन कोई
नहीं
है जिस दिन सिलेबस कंप्लीट कर देंगे आप
सबको समझ में आ जाएगा स चीज डाउट आपके
क्लियर हो जाएंगे उस दिन कोर्स को खत्म कर
देंगे कोस को तब तक चलाएंगे जब तक आप
लोगों के डाउट रहेंगे कोर्स आपके ऊपर
डिपेंड करता है बस आप लोगों में कोई भी
डाउट नहीं बना कोई भीरी नहीं बचना चाहिए
आप मास्टर हो जाने चाहिए जिस दिन आप
मास्टर बन जाओगे उस दिन कोर्स खत्म कर
देंगे देर इ नो ड्यूरेशन ऑफ दिस कोर्स पर
एटलीस्ट 40 लेक्चर तक जाएगा यह 40 तक
जाएगा 35 40 लेक्चर जाएगा ही जाएगा
क्योंकि इतना बड़ा इसका सिलेबस है मेरे
पास जो मैं आपको करवाने वाला हूं भगा भगा
के नहीं बिल्कुल आराम आराम से इंटरेस्टिंग
वे में आपका सिलेबस करवाने वाला
हूं
और बताइए और
पूछ नो सलूशन एड से प्रैक्टिस नहीं कर
सकते आपको लैपटॉप लेना ही
पड़ेगा वि लैपटॉप प्रैक्टिस नहीं कर सकते
न साइबर सिक इंडस्ट्री में आप एक कदम नहीं
बढ़ सकते विदाउट लैपटॉप
क्योंकि आप फोन से कितना कर सकते हो फन से
थ्योरी कर सकते हो बट प्रैक्टिकल कुछ नहीं
कर सकते एड फोन
से नॉट एट ल आपको लैपटॉप परचेज ही करना
पड़ेगा अदर वाइज अगर आपके हिम्मत है तो
अगर आप चाहो तो उसमें जा सकते हो साइबर
कैफ में ब व आपको उतना कॉस्टली पड़ जाएगा
उसको चीज आपको चलाने में नहीं देंगे
अल्टरनेट ऑप्शन आपको क्या क्लाउड यूज करना
क्लाउड में आपका कॉस्टली पड़ जाएगा
स्टार्टिंग हा कोस्टली नहीं फ्री होता है
एक मशीना फ्री आपने मशीन होस्ट कर सकते हो
प्रैक्टिस के लिए बट क्या है कि आपको फिर
उसका साइबर कैप को तो बिल देना ही
पड़ेगा ओके सुनील यू कैन गो इट न तो मुझे
लगता है किसी कोई डाउट नहीं है हम सेशन
एंड कर सकते हैं प्लीज नेक्स्ट न मिनट में
बता कोई भी कोई डाउट है तो बता दि यस या
नो उसके बा सेशन एंड करने दिए किसी को काम
होगा इंपोर्टेंट वो जा सकता है फि
ग्रुप में ऐड हो
र ग्रुप में ऐड हो जाइए सर्विसी जी आप
यहां पर डिस्क्रिप्शन में जाइए टेलीग्राम
का ग्रुप है वहां पर जाइए और ऐड हो जाइए
वहां पर सब कुछ मिलेगा आपको नोट्स भी है
सब
कुछ
नहीं किसने दिया अ डीसीएसपी के कोर्स फ्री
में आई थम किसी ने नहीं दिया ओके नॉर्मल
आई डोंट नो कि आपको मिला होगा नहीं मिला
होगा
बट मेरी वजह से कैसे मिल गया
भाई
ओके सेशन एंड करते हैं बाय बाय